[Music]
do you guys like wearing face masks
just kidding no no not jeffy yes but
like this
people oh you know what i was thinking
i'm a stupid idiot i was thinking like
the
facial kind i was like i hate this sheet
mess
yeah people get so bad because i just
say i wear masks to be polite
and i still wear the mask but everyone's
like that's not you shouldn't you should
you should also say the right thing
you should also say the right thing
while you wear the mask what's the right
thing i don't know i'm supposed to read
their [ __ ] script why were they
the right thing is oh you're supposed to
be responsible
and i love you wear your masks and i
love it but being respectful
is being responsible i'm wearing the
mask no but we're going
on a meditation i wear two masks
yeah i don't just wear one but i wear
two look at that
i actually like wearing the mask when
we're all out in public and i see other
people wearing masks i'm like
dude i'm much hotter with a mask on i
gotta say a lot of people are oh my god
i've met so many people with a mask on
and i'm like wow they're really
attractive
and then they take it off and i'm like
oh [ __ ] i wasn't expecting this part
to look like that the masks doesn't
bother me one bit
it doesn't japanese perverts wear these
masks what the [ __ ] going on over
there
what's going on how do they even spy on
people like that yeah
are they perverse no the others wait
pull it up higher
yeah there you go oh yeah i'm a doctor
doctor ninja
you're not a pervert you wouldn't know
like super yeah like they're
super stupid
oh [ __ ] damn that's like a medieval
night's mask
dude he's a cg shredder right now
he's got the balls on it the motion
capture
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
all right so we don't like wearing masks
i just said i don't mind i just said i
don't mind i just said i [ __ ] love it
oh right we love where i'm at i'm
reading the script all right
so we love it there's no screen just
took the first answer that's true i i
latched on to his first answer
so we like wearing masks what about
guns i like wearing guns you like
wearing they're very fashionable really
yeah do you wear a gun on a holster
oh those oh look at those guns
that's pretty fashionable you know what
i mean that's pretty fashionable
would you guys say wearing a gun like
this is fashionable
wait what [ __ ] your gun-free zone is the
barrel
i don't understand oh wait that's a gun
holster
holy [ __ ] it's pointing at his heart
it's like right at his throat or
like yeah that's so stupid so he's got a
[ __ ]
you could you could actually lose your
your eardrum doing this
jaws out isn't it hella heavy too so
yeah how heavy is that [ __ ]
this guy's dumb dude very dumb what are
you thinking can you imagine these guys
at the [ __ ] uh
like the uh competitions that we do and
they're [ __ ] running drills
[Music]
it's like this oh yeah or he pulls it
and his mask comes up and then he
catches corona and [ __ ]
or he blinds himself with the mask
because it gets caught
but what's the statement he's like yo
ask me to take my mask off and i was
like
this is it looks like a troll i feel
like it's the same [ __ ] where people
were taking selfies where like pointing
their gun to their dick with a loaded
gun on the trigger it's like i feel like
you know that
she shot himself in the dick there's a
cliff
he's just like pointing and then it just
goes off and he's like oh [ __ ] i [ __ ]
up
poor guy oh she keep it did he lose it
did he put in the ice chest in time
don't no actually never follow i'd never
bothered to follow up i thought he was
just an idiot
all right so this guy is another idiot
who decided to make
a a political statement i do like his
shirt though [ __ ] your gun-free zone
true we can we can agree on certain
things but we'll know the gun free zone
will allow a bad guy into it
there's a perimeter that's correct
that's true true but
so this guy decided to put a holster on
his mask
and put a gun there and he's basically
protesting against the fact that he
doesn't
protesting against two things he doesn't
like to wear a mask
then why where also well if i'm gonna
wear a mask because you're forcing me to
wear a mask then he's gonna make it
uncomfortable for you
that's a good thing for you bro you got
a [ __ ] you got a [ __ ] eight-pound
gun on your face do not care that you're
pointing it to your own neck
this guy's so stupid he's one of those
guys that's trying to make a statement
out both sides hate him
yeah exactly exactly exactly and he's
like where are my team at and then this
team's like you're [ __ ] done
and all of us who are like into gun
rights are looking at them like
that's not how we do it bro sorry about
that that's not that's not what
what we're trying to do here bro you
don't ever have a holster pointed at
your [ __ ] body first of all and
second one third of all
and you don't use tablecloth material to
make a face mask
true i think that is the best material
to use no
cotton i that's i mean early pandemic
days that's what they were saying to use
cotton masks yeah but you look like such
a homemaker when you're not you know
exactly especially the pattern that he
picked it looks like it belongs on an
apron yeah
it really does actually yeah we're
getting his ass good right now
[ __ ] he deserves it so true
but yeah so it seems like most people
are reacting regardless of political
agenda and and beliefs or whatever we're
missing the silver lining here
this is the first time that both sides
have been in
unity yeah so we're united
i feel like we can all unite together
against stupid people
yeah democrats and republicans getting
together
gun rights activists and anti-gun people
getting together and saying
yeah anti-massacres and mass they're
like yo you're [ __ ] dumb bro what the
[ __ ] and how about vaxxers and
anti-taxes maybe they can find some
common ground here i don't know i don't
know
dude you're pushing you're pushing me
marvel and dc
people coming together no that that
won't happen that won't happen no
okay that's a pipe dream dude
i love it when people like try to stand
and make a statement and they think
everyone else is going to be like [ __ ]
yeah bro america
and then they're just like nah that's
not it he's the guy that's like
i was thinking of that guy too
[Laughter]
everyone's like shut up
shut down this is like the literature
not the way to do
it this is like the libertarian person
uh who's like
i should be able to own a nuclear weapon
and everyone's like oh god just get off
the stage man just [ __ ] stop it
yeah it's like libertarianism is awesome
and then
we have idiots that comes in and goes uh
yeah i should be independent away from
the government
this and that and i'm all like not guys
like you
no no no no he's like i made my own
nuclear weapon i'm like no no no no no
no no no no no we just uh we weren't
picturing you when we thought about this
political party
how high do you think his truck is oh
god oh
to the ceiling okay and how big are
those plastic balls that he hangs at the
back of them
how useless are his mud flaps which flip
rocks no matter what the [ __ ] one
two tires yeah on the back that was
tight yeah got a huge fat ass on his
truck
because of the double tires they're
gigantic
that's that guy isn't that crazy we can
imagine this guy's life yeah just by
looking at
who he is probably got an atv and a
motocross bike
yeah he's got a [ __ ] dog with the
collar with the spikes
i hate that he probably likes monster
energy drinks which is [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up don't assume
there's a kind for monster energy drinks
you've seen the decals
probably watches football too oh yeah
he's definitely a monday night football
guys
let's not go there okay why did you the
colts fan
no no no no no no no so what else do we
know about this guy what is this
that's pretty much it i mean i think
twitter was pretty pretty much unanimous
uh
you know this guy responded this is
hilarious this isn't responsible for
firearm views this is
exhibitionism you are looking at a
full-on
kink proudly displayed to the public
because that
person gets off on the discomfort it
will create in others and that's pretty
much what's really happening with a lot
of these types of like
strange demonstrations jerking right now
uh yeah he's getting off on the fact
that everyone else is
uncomfortable around him this is like
telling a bad joke and being like well
it was comedy it's like
good for you no this guy's the one that
goes to facebook
and then he's the one complaining and
starting a poll of like wait why should
i
put on my face mask first in case of an
emergency if the plane's crashing i'm
gonna put it on my kid first
my love for my child yeah exactly you're
exactly right
that's true yeah that's embarrassing so
what when he posted this what was the
caption
uh you know what i don't know first it's
the mask then it's our freedom
or maybe the caption is no caption
needed
oh that's sick you know what i don't
well it doesn't even have the uh
original post here or it's all retweets
or he's not good at hashtags his hashtag
is hashtag
mask gun face that's like there's nobody
following it doesn't have a ring to it
right yeah it doesn't normally nobody
used it
but you really got circulated because
other of other people don't think mass
gun fades gonna be big
have you guys studied their the the the
anti-masters
and like why they think a certain way
why they're up against it they think
it's a
full-on conspiracy right there is no
ronaldo the slippery slope argument
again i mean
for is like yeah it's literally first
they make you
wear the masks it's not even legal it's
not constitutional
then the next thing is they'll tap your
phones or whatever
it's just think of the worst possible
controlling thing pos you know like it's
like this is how they
get us groomed and to now blindly
following orders
and just continuing on with that is it
really that though like is it really
like the political agenda and that's
it's as simple as that because for me
i'm like
i'm not crazy about wearing masks but
like
like you said i'm like i'll respect what
you know everyone wants
like other countries they did it and
then they did away with it
and no one's continuing to wear masks
there's no policies that changed or
anything
so like i'm not opposed to
any argument right i'll listen to it but
then to me it's just
everything is so it's like it's a
slippery slope everywhere like
everything is like
you first they wear the mask and then
you're gay or like some kind of crazy
[ __ ] yeah like what is
that hits construction cones because
he's like
you can't [ __ ] tell me what to do i'm
american and all this [ __ ] yeah
it's like bro it's just a guideline
because there's construction workers may
be in danger right
yeah i don't need a driver's license
because it's unconstitutional
you know what i mean like here i am i'm
the guy who i don't like the
construction cones i think it sucks ass
but i'm like no you know what
i'm i understand that there's someone in
there right now
and so i should just follow the traffic
like everyone else but i can complain
about it and everybody
but you know everyone wants me to read
the [ __ ] script and go i like to
follow the construction codes it's so
fun and good and it's good it's good for
society
and i'm like i don't have to say that
just be i'm still doing all the right
things but i'm just not saying it the
way you want me to so what and i think
it's okay
to criticize and and scrutinize certain
laws and
ideas right but then we have to change
the laws from the inside you can't
you can't uh you can't just sit there
and on both yeah you have anarchy
that's true i'm not for that yeah so i
wear the [ __ ] mask
there you go i'm just not that happy
about it if you don't like it then
go through the same the right process of
to change it
going through the system and changing it
yeah not
get tablecloth make a mask make other
people uncomfortable at the grocery
store
who's not gonna actually you're not
gonna make a difference that way you do
nothing
yeah yeah i'm making a stand it's not
effective
cool dude you're pancaking [ __ ] uh
construction cones
yeah i'll [ __ ] play i'll play a bongo
drum at the parking lot and talk about
my rights
and like no one's gonna it doesn't do
anything yeah it gathered a crowd of
three
yeah you made three dollars and seventy
cents and good for you
someone gave him 70 cents he put 370 in
oh to make it look like you know just
just jump started yeah
the other one was from my grandma
[Music]
you